pour kiev la capitale ukrainienne où on
continue de se préparer à la soluce les
charges sont à sa porte la ville s'est
vidée de ses habitants ceux qui sont
restés sont déterminés à la défendre
coûte que coûte cyril payet avec lui en
duplex de kiev bonjour cyril comment
s'est déroulée cette nuit de samedi à
dimanche là où vous êtes
écoutez philo mais le couvre-feu s'est
élevé à 7 heures comme seka maintenant
comme une forme de routine hélas pour
des dizaines de milliers d'habitants de
de kiev et voilà à quoi ressemble un ce
matin un dimanche matin dans la capitale
d'un pays européen kiev nous sommes
devant la cathédrale sainte vladimir
quête d'indicés lieux saints de la ville
qui devrait un dimanche matin selon le
culte orthodoxe est rempli de
paroissiens bas comme vous pouvez le
voir il n'y a personne et ce qui est
saisissant c'est que il y a eu les
carillons de la messe qui viennent de
s'arrêter et qui sont ponctuées de puits
au moment où je vous parle par des
bombardements qu'on entend de manière
incessante depuis ce matin qui sont en
direction du nord c'est à dire le nord
ouest sans doute la ville d'hier pink et
à une quarantaine de kilomètres de là où
on se trouve où il ya des combats
pourtant on entend vraiment je vous
parle des bombardements dont on sait
qu'un pont qui menait qui traversait la
ville d'hier pays n'a été sabotés par
les forces ukrainienne pour éviter la
progression ou ralentir la progression
des forces russes il ya des combats qui
font rage donc aux portes de kiev
sachant que mon c'est qu'évidemment que
le nord l'est sont dans une position
difficile là il s'agit maintenant de
l'ouest le norway cette pression
implacable même si elle est plus lente
que prévu qui s'accentue sur la ville
qui n'a plus qu'un accès sud cet accès
sud par lequel nous avons pu rentrer
dans dans kiev donc voilà à quoi
ressemble cette ville nous sommes sur
l'une des artères les plus importantes
de la ville il y a personne quelques
voitures évidemment et pouvait voir je
ne sais pas si vous avez entendu ce
bombardement important des explosions et
écouter une vie samedi un dimanche matin
dans cette capitale ukrainienne qui
devrait être remplie de monde où il n'y
a absolument personne encore une fois un
constat de ville ce matin une ville
fantôme un quartier central de kiev
quasiment fantôme par ailleurs cyril on
peut ajouter que les milices
d'autodéfense les groupes d'autodéfense
sont aussi structuré toujours pour
défendre cette ville
oui c'est très très saisissant après les
centaines de kilomètres que nous avons
parcouru pour traverser ce pays pour
arriver depuis la frontière polonaise à
700 km à l'ouest de là où se trouve vers
la capitale eh bien il ya un
renforcement
incroyable très saisissant etc
spectaculaire je dois dire un du système
d'autodéfense il y avait bien des
miliciens qui sont en fait des personnes
des hommes pour la plupart qui sont
restés derrière des riverains des
habitants de cette ville qui la
défendent quartier par quartier rond
point par an points à chaque endroit de
délai les coins de rue où nous nous
trouvons qui sont qui jonchent et bien
ceux qui jonchent cet axe c'est le grand
âge sept grandes avenues il y à des
barricades des checkpoints des barrages
avec des hommes en armes qui continuent
de mettre des sacs de remplis de terre
pour tenter de préparer cette défense
puisque évidemment 6,7 ce grand assaut
notamment qui était prévu par ce long
convoi de blindés qu'on attendait depuis
quelques jours et ralentit maintenant on
sait que cette offensive éclair qui a
été prévu par le l'état-major russe
n'arrivera pas ils n'ont ils n'en
restent pas moins et on le disait à
l'instant que la pression militaire
contre kiev et contre les villes de
d'ukraine continue par le le sud on en
parlait par le nord par l'est et cette
pression implacable dont personne ne
doute aux personnes au doute ici qui va
finir par fondre sur kiev avec ce siège
et bien qu'on attend d'un jour où d'une
semaine à l'autre ici mais je peux vous
dire que pour les habitants qui sont
encore là tout le monde est préparé à
rester ici pour défendre cette ville
comme une sorte de symbole contre
l'invasion russe si cyril payen vol
spécial de france 24 à kiev merci aussi
georges yazbek qui signe les images pour
vous merci